oh that's the question you feel brave
enough
why not
stupid enough
go on
wait no I I said it I said oh okay okay
I said if you're stupid enough then yeah
go for it like yeah but no not more so
than anything of date who you want more
so you just understand that there are
consequences for dating
women that have chosen to make those
decisions and if you're able to live
with the consequences
kudos to you but more so you should
understand that you won't like the
repercussions of what is going to come
out of that I guess it depends on if
they've healed or not yeah like
probably I was just about to say you can
have a bad boy face because you're going
through something maybe you're young
you've got issues people mature people
grow like women grow they change yeah
but the problem is
this is this is the issue that a lot of
men find themselves in is the girls
really wanted the bad boys
they just accepted the the uh the nice
guy because they couldn't lock the bad
boy down
and really
that's who they want to be with is it or
is it just maybe you have trauma and
this person that treats you like [__]
you're like oh I'm so attracted to him
but it's because your father was
disapproving of you and so you want this
person that rejects you um
I mean I don't know
well I think women are attracted to
traits like they call it the dark Triad
train so women are attracted to traits
that are like negative about guys
because they're also positive like the
guy like why why do why do we dig as
that punch holes in the wall it's
because the same guy that is super
aggressive like maybe towards us and
just in general can also protect us
oh yeah okay so yeah yeah so it's like a
double the same guy that treats you like
[__] it shows that he thinks highly of
himself because he can stand up for
himself
okay
and so what a lot of guys finally said
20 to 25 of marriages are sexless
and typically it's the woman holding out
like guys want to have sex yeah but is
that because she's repressed because
women are either demonized for being
sexual or they're taught Hydro sexuality
you need to be more than that I think
they're first in a marriage yeah yeah
but why why are they repressed sexually
but why would you be repressed in
America
because you could be brought up in a
family where sex is very taboo and as a
woman you even you need to be more than
pretty but I feel like but even in like
say we take the Catholic church or Islam
once you get married you're supposed to
be chop chop chop chop contraception so
I don't really understand that one yeah
every day the message is always like
wait till marriage I feel like it's not
they're not like don't have sex but it's
also like don't be sexual outside of
marriage and if you grow up with someone
saying like cover yourself up oh don't
put yourself on display don't don't
express yourself in that way
we think all of a sudden when you're
married you're going to be like Oh I'm
this wild sensual woman
yeah did you say could I say nobody gets
uh married quicker than two horny
Muslims because you wanna go and do the
job that you've been suppressed okay
yeah I don't think women are suppressed
in society at all I think we're actually
rewarded for being sexual I mean you get
more followers on Instagram you get more
DMS you get you can make money on only
fans and even when people try to shame
women and say hey that's that's whole
Behavior they're they're they say [__]
shaming so they'll shame men for shaming
women
okay so I don't really think women are
you know but then even if you are in on
Instagram or being whatever it's just
slash shamed or whatever you're doing
just because someone is doing that to
you doesn't mean that you are then more
likely to get married what do you mean
so if you're very promiscuous and open
about it
are you gonna be married that's true
you're correct probably not women that
tend to be married perhaps are more
traditional and would hide their
sexuality be a bit more covert and and
portray this image of like
Purity yes
yeah
especially depends on the environment
that you're in as well your background
your culture everything has a factor on
that as well yeah
I feel like that would also like that
kind of home training would also be
associated with being like submissive to
your husband so then the sexual side
would come into it when he initiates it
but that doesn't mean you feel
comfortable in your sexuality he might
want to go all the time and you haven't
learned to express it you are if it's
the right guy you wanna you wanna have
sex all the time every girl has had a
guy that she wants to have sex all the
time I mean that's the one you marry no
I know but that's the point that's why
that's why like that's the whole point
is because because you're marrying yeah
because you're marrying the guy that
you're not that attracted to and so like
basically the more Partners a woman has
the less likely she is to have a happy
marriage so if someone has a bad boy
past like she's less likely to be
satisfied in her marriage because if
you're a virgin when you get married if
you have an 80 chance of getting into a
happy marriage after 10 years if you
have had sex with more than five people
which I think most men pray for nowadays
and
um it drops down to 20 25 percent okay
and so I think that's why historically
we've always protected women and like
tell them to like not be sexual outside
of marriage because the bond like the
bond is so strong for women during sex
we release a hormone during sex that men
don't oxytocin yeah and the more you
have sex with people the less you
release it's like a defense mechanism
basically yeah that's interesting hmm
and it all comes to that Bundy you're
saying of uh the person that you marry
you might not actually be satisfied with
sexually
oxytocin is only released when you
actually come so if you're with a guy he
doesn't make you come you're not gonna
have that one the husband
[Music]
what if it happened wait say that again
your husband what if it happens what if
he if he if he doesn't get you there
well why would you let's say
hypocratically we're not talking about
anyone but say why would you ever marry
someone like that because you're a
virgin and it's
well if you're a virgin if if you're a
virgin you don't know different I hear
it so like how would you know the sex is
bad if you're a virgin I hate it well
and some girls don't have the option
like you can't have everything in a guy
so when do they realize that [__] or did
they just go on thinking this [__] that
whole life what do you well I think I
mean the average age of first marriage
in the UK is 31. yeah it makes sense
no yeah so it's like those those girls I
mean they've obviously if they start
having sex at 16 like one a year that's
like at least 12 13 right they've done a
med team yeah
and so and so it's like
I mean you can't have everything and I
think when you time's running out you
got to pick what you want so some girls
are going to marry the guy they're not
attracted to but the problem is the guys
don't know that
because he thinks that as men are
insecurities we always want a woman
that's more attractive than us so we
think oh yeah we've hit the jackpot
really and truly you're like cursed like
10th pick we've got a hundredth pick
when that's your prime a number one and
you've worked his whole life like no one
ever liked you and you worked your whole
life to become an accountant
worked for 10 years and you finally got
someone sloppy seconds and you're so
happy but she's sloppy at the end of the
day
it's a life story oh my God